where we have to start because i read a
lot about this yesterday after we
watched this crash happen
what is elon musk's beef with
the u.s government yeah and first of all
i love that
graphic i love i i mean i could watch
that all day
behind you it was and by the way the
spacex
launch commentator said we need to work
on that landing
afterwards anyway on the side so so to
answer your question
basically just kind of you know boil it
all down
spacex has asked the fcc federal
communications commission
uh to allow the company to allow spacex
to basically
lower the orbit of its starlink
satellite so
spacex has been sending up we've
reported about this all
these satellites into orbit as part of
its new like broadband
you know world internet's broadband
service it's called the starlink
constellation so
spacex wants to lower the orbit of those
satellites but then
amazon objected saying no that's going
to interfere with
our satellites as prod as part of
project kuiper
uh and the 3000 plus satellites that
amazon
is going to send into orbit yeah elon
musk elon musk said yesterday
the fcc faa us government is keeping us
from getting to mars
he said that we yeah he he also tweeted
so when amazon
raised this objection he said uh he he
fired off a tweet he said
this does not serve the public to
hamstring starling today
for an amazon satellite system that is
at best several years away from
operation
so it's a battle of the billionaires
over their claim to space
and to basically you know their right to
orbit and meanwhile we're looking at
pictures like this i understand that
elon musk said he's going to get a
rocket up in space with two astronauts
by the end of this year so it's not only
you know bezos and musk battling and
you know over you know control of of
orbit for their satellites
but also it's the space race to send not
only astronauts as part of the
public-private partnership
that spacex is involved in with nasa but
sending civilians
can you imagine that i would like to go
up well yeah
but they've already said keep in mind
they've already sent the dragon rocket
remember with the two astronauts the
nasa astronauts
last year that we reported about so
they're already working in that
partnership
blue origin you know bezos is blue
origin wants to
develop a partnership and work with nasa
as well as part of this again
public private cooperation you know in
the space race so
this is i mean you could say i guess
it's kind of foreshadowing
of the the space race to come
between billionaires battling and
jostling for position
in orbit
you